[Music]
the terminator franchise exists on a
unique
plane of existence too formulaic to live
but possessing too much brand
recognition to die
the series has spawned four film entries
and a tv show since the turn of the
century
each of which has generally been met
with a collective resigned
psy and a widespread sense that it was
life imitating art
just like the characters in the movies
film fans knew that there was a grim
future ahead of them but there seemed to
be no way to avoid it
but then 2019's terminator dark fate
suddenly offered a ray of hope
an alternate timeline we could all live
in where suddenly the movies were good
and popular again with james cameron
helping to pen the story
deadpool's tim miller in the director's
chair and linda hamilton returning to
the role of sarah connor for the first
time since 1991
terminator dark fate had all the makings
of a brand new day for killer cyborgs
as an added bonus it even ignored rise
of the machines
salvation and genesis that's exactly the
kind of retconning that this killer
robot story needed
and it looked to be coming at a time
when interest in sci-fi film and 80s
revivals was at its peak
and then hasta la vista baby
yes much to everybody's disappointment
the movie was a bit of a box office done
according to box office mojo dark fate
pulled in 261 million dollars on a 185
million dollar budget
with just 62 million dollars coming from
u.s ticket sales
but the film wasn't actually bad rotten
tomatoes ranked it as the most
critically acclaimed big screen entry in
the series since
judgment day so why didn't it succeed
according to dark fate star mackenzie
davis the answer is simple
people are just sick of the franchise
appearing as a guest on the happy sad
confused podcast
davis said as far as the box office and
stuff it's terminator six
nobody saw the last three i get it it's
okay
i don't think that means what we made
was bad but i understand that the
audience's appetite has been exhausted
it makes sense even star wars has shown
signs of fan fatigue in recent years and
that's a franchise with a much broader
footprint than the terminator
which relies on one or two characters
going through the same storyline
over and over it's hard to live down the
multiple disappointments that terminator
fans have endured over the past two
decades
most fans will forgive a single misstep
the very few will keep coming back to
the well for years and years if the
water keeps coming up poisoned
dark fate could have been one of the
best terminator movies ever made
and according to some fans and critics
it was but it still had to contend with
the legacy of its predecessors when it
came to getting viewers in the door
some have also floated a bleaker
explanation for why dark fate
underperformed at the box office
sexism which often tends to be the
elephant in the room with
underperforming female-led action movies
dark fate features a main cast made up
entirely of female performers
a point which internet trolls clung to
with a skeletal metal grip
davis doesn't subscribe to that thesis
however speaking about the movies and
performance she said
how much you attribute that to there
being three women in the lead i don't
know
i never really wanted to engage with
that stuff because i can't control it
i am a woman and i really like the part
and i felt proud of what i did so i
couldn't be like
no one's seeing it because they're
sexist it seemed like an easier answer
for me to be like
alright six is too much now we know the
good news
davis career is doing fine in 2020 alone
davis appeared in jon stewart's
irresistible and the hulu smash hit
happiest season
the bad news since the release of dark
fate there's no word on when
if ever the terminator may return but
hey
you know what they say i'll be back
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one